With that we conclude discussion of synchronization
and communication issues in parallel systems. The next
part of the lesson will cover scheduling issues
in parallel systems. You'll notice once again when
we discuss scheduling issues that the mantra
is always the same. Namely, pay attention to
keeping the caches warm to ensure good performance.
We're going to look at scheduling issues in
parallel systems. Fundamentally, the typical behavior of
any thread or process running on a processor is to do the following: compute for
a while and then make a blocking IO system call or it might want
to snychronize with other threads that it is part
of in the application or it might be that
it is a compute bond thread, in which case
it might just run out of the time quantum that
it has been given by the scheduler on the
processor. But fundamentally what that means is this is
a point at which the operating system, in particular
the scheduler piece of the operating system, can schedule
some other thread or process to run on the
CPU. So how should the scheduler go about picking
the next thread or process to run in the
processors, given that it had the choice of other threads
that in can run at any point of time?